What we're watching here is
a government funding
of a militarization of the
police.
A door swung open in the late
sixties.
Nothing that big or bright
had ever happened.
And in so many American cities.
And someone, something
sprang up and slammed it shut.
Riotsville, USA a new documentary by
filmmaker Sierra Pettengill, is
a surrealist look at the dawn of
police militarization in America.
Following the death of Michael Brown
in Ferguson, Missouri, Americans
became increasingly aware of the
growing use of military tools
and tactics by law enforcement.
But as Pettengill's film makes
clear, the practice began decades
earlier in the 1960s after
protests erupted in cities across
the country.
In 1967, President Lyndon
Johnson appointed the Kerner
Commission to study what had caused
a series of urban riots that led
to deadly clashes between protesters
and police.
The commission's report recommended
an ambitious set of initiatives to
combat racism in America
and a minor measure calling for
increased funding and training for
police.
It was that minor recommendation
that President Johnson latched on
to.
One conclusion is that the police in
the military fell, people were shot,
people died, that strategically
there was a need for reform.
And so Riotsville
in ways that are very important for
me, in how I think about the present
tense is a really direct
example of what police reform looks
like in practice.
Riotsville was
a series of fake towns
that looked like the low budget film
sets that were constructed on
military bases in
the late sixties for
training in civil disturbance
control.
People ranging from FBI agents
to governors,
rank and file police officers,
police chiefs were all brought
in for this course and Riotsville
was a sort of day long staged
reenactment.
What they're expecting when they go
there is to learn about coordination
between departments, how
communication should be happening.
They are learning how
a riot typically unfolds,
which is an invention and a creation
of the military and the government
that sort of reinforces itself.
We need a new school board for this
town. Right.
That thing looks like it took Henry
Ford to school
and playgrounds.
We haven't got one playground in
this town, do we?
Isolated and secured
from outside interference or
agitation.
Such demonstrations will usually
terminate peacefully in a minimum
of time.
Now an incident will demand more
positive action.
They don't tell me what to do, man.
I'm a civilian.
You doing my time and
that army. You know, in these stage
demonstrations, the men dressed
in black will typify hardcore
professional agitators.
When the group refuses to disband.
Action must be taken.
Now the agitators shift their
troublemaking skills into high gear,
using the naturally contagious
qualities of excitement and violence
to incite them into action.
It's largely the first time that
the federal government is funding
local police departments directly.
Federal allocation for local police
went from $0 in 1964
to 10 million in 65,
and then by 1970 was 300
million.
The same rhetoric for police reform
now, which is you can
you can pull a lot of things under
the rubric of how to reduce harm,
but here's a tank just in case.
You know, what the justifications
are for grant writing purposes
versus what's actually being
experienced on the ground are
often at odds.
A great deal of the archival footage
used in the film was shot by the
military.
Pettengill, an archival researcher
was particularly drawn to the
government films.
Finding a visual record
of the fantasy space
of what the government and the
military,
how they are designing the world.
You know, they're building their own
city and they're populating it and
they're scripting the actions.
And I feel like that's a very rare
thing to come across as a
sort of visual representation of
of what they think, how they
conceive of the world.
When I saw the footage, the first
thing I was struck by was this
simultaneous, deep absurdity
and stupidity.
It's really dumb and bumbling and
and and bad.
And you do want to laugh
at parts. And then extreme,
pretty chilling violence.
And the pairing of those two
things does feel like
what it feels like to be living in
in America in many ways.
And that was a real guiding force in
the edit room was
how do you make this absurdity
reflective of the callousness
and lack of care and attention
on the part of the military
to government?
The film takes pains to make the
viewer aware of its manipulations
with jump cuts, digital artifacts
and jarring editing choices.
The goal is to drive home that what
you're seeing, like Riotsville
itself, is constructed.
The idea of being in an immersive
documentary where you feel like
you're right there and you're in it
and you're living through it, is not
actually an
accurate way of experiencing
things. And to me, it's
very important that we are watching
this for a reason, which is the
reason we keep asking What are we
looking at? What do we make of this?
What do we make of this in the
future it was meant to insure?
And so not hiding the
digital nature of things and and
in some ways trying to probe as far
in as you can get and see what's
there and see the limitations of the
pixels.
The film is pretty self-aware
in its construction, and one
of the most important political
points to me and the film is that
this is all constructed, that we do
not live in a historical
inevitability.
We are not forced to live in a
really repressive, brutal state.